autres pays européens l'espagne toute
personne venant de l'autre côté des
pyrénées se verra imposer une série de
mesures de quarantaine
un principe de réciprocité pris par
paris après une décision similaire à
celle prise par madrid qui sera
effective jusqu'au 24 mai exempté les
travailleurs frontaliers notamment
l'espagne ou plusieurs manifestations en
hommage aux personnels soignants ont eu
lieu hier
trente cinq mille d'entre eux ont été
testés positifs en coronavirus depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire plus de
précisions à barcelone avec notre
correspondante leslie son glas en
espagne 49 soignantes sont décédées des
suites du coronavirus le pays compte
désormais plus de 35000 quatre parmi les
professionnels de la santé ce qui
représente 22 % du nombre total de
cartes de colleville 19 durant le pic de
l'épidémie l'espagne avait même le taux
le plus élevé d'europe parmi les
professionnels de la santé
deux minutes de silence ont été réalisés
dans les hôpitaux pour rendre hommage à
ces personnes décédées elle travaillait
dans différents services notamment aux
urgences cet hommage a été convoqué par
des associations et syndicats de
professionnels du pays
l invité le personnel de santé à
s'arrêter durant deux minutes à leur
poste de travail ce geste de
reconnaissance devait s'effectuer sans
bouger pas de grande concentration
devant les hôpitaux afin de respecter
les mesures de sécurité il a également
été demandé aux espagnols de diffuser
des messages de soutien pour soutenir
les familles des victimes
le personnel de santé travaillant
premières vignes
la crise et le début de la crise fut
très compliqué en espagne en raison du
manque de matériel de protection mais
aussi d'espacés de personnel dans les
hôpitaux
les professionnels étaient mobilisés
sept jours sur sept et pour beaucoup de
soignants ce manque de matériel et de
protection expliquerai les chiffres très
élevés en espagne
et parmi les soignants espagnols testés
positifs cet infectiologue
on écoute moi je fais partie le service
des maladies infectieuses dont un tennis
en première ligne depuis le début donc
on a on a vu presque tous le médecin de
service des maladies infectieuses à
arrêter les activités comme fait c'est
de façon régulière faire face aux cas
croissant nombre croissant de cas
d'e.coli et puis effectivement noah il y
en avait offert une escalade reste
important du nombre d'unités qui fait
face au casse d oka déco vide et moi
c'était en tant que coordinateur d'une
immunité pendant quelques semaines
jusqu'au finalement - gt gt infectés je
veux rester à la maison trois semaines
avant de promettre encore prêt